I wasn't planning on doing a video I
really wasn't planning on doing a video
on Super Tuesday because I'm not a
wonkish guy I'm not a micro policy guy
more you know the show's more cultural I
leave it to the Talking Heads I just
think that they're wrong what do I think
is happening today I don't think they're
maybe I just can't picture a better case
scenario for President Trump I don't
have a bit of a shoulder injury so it
was too tall in order to fill my own
video so my wife is filming today so
yeah just for verification to squeeze
the posterior that's the beauty of
having a ring I can do it whenever I
want
I don't need consent so I don't want to
hear your opinion on Super Tuesday I
think Donald Trump must be just gleeful
right now spilled a celebratory Diet
Coke all over his McDouble because um
Bernie Sanders this is equivalent Bernie
Sanders will light a house fire and walk
away laughing that's what's going to
happen here so the best case scenario
for Democrats would have been a very
clear winner right whether it's whether
it's Bernie whether it's fighting take
your pick it still would have been ideal
for there to be a clear-cut winner
Elizabeth Warren is not doing well
apparently she's not dropping out you
have to subscribe to these newsletters
and she was asking for more money which
probably not the best investment at this
point I think I think you could probably
purchase some stock in New Coke and do
better um but there's this idea to that
first up let me let me kind of segment
this if Elizabeth Warren drops out
people are assuming that all of her
voters will go to Bernie I don't believe
that the case I think it might be a
60/40 split to Bernie versus buying okay
so even if Elizabeth Warren drops out
that's really a non-issue I don't think
it affects the primary sort of conflict
here which is Joe Biden Bernie Sanders
Bernie Sanders is not going to concede
so this is going to be dirty it's going
to go all the way to convention and
whoever wins is going to be hobbling you
know in to the general and here's
something else I noticed with Bernie
Sanders when he's attacking Joe Biden
Donald Trump should just be taking notes
if you look at the speeches that Bernie
Sanders delivered or the main speech
that he delivered yesterday and super
I don't know where he was delivering the
the state it escapes me right now the
things that he espoused the policies he
espoused that got the biggest cheers
we're actually very similar to Donald
Trump's the things that he espoused that
are most palatable to middle Americans
right that sort of Rust Belt where we
think Bernie would do well he said I he
was opposed to the war right needs to
Joe Biden voted for the world I was
opposed to the word guess who else was
opposed to the war Donald Trump he said
Joe Biden is support of these horrible
trade agreements now listen what do you
think Donald Trump's right or wrong I
think it really is an arguable that
Donald Trump has done more to reverse
course on our at least or the standard
trade policy that we've had with her
stood after TPP than any president in
modern history so these things got
thunderous applause from Bernie Sanders
and I think by the way it's probably
going to be Biden in the general so
what's what's Donald Trump going to do
he's basically going to attack Joe Biden
the same way that Bernie Sanders has
Bernie Sanders is already providing this
contrast to this elitist Joe Biden to
the point and here's something else I
think is important too
Bernie's going to drop out let's let's
assume the scenario burn if Bernie wins
he's probably going to lose okay
the likely scenario is that Biden wins
okay so if Biden wins Bernie drops out I
think that a lot of the Talking Heads
again I think they're wrong you let me
know what you think I could be wrong
listen Charles Krauthammer I got it
right fifty percent of the time it was
one of the best ever I figure me here in
my office Jordan Peterson look it's very
clean I probably don't really have that
much of a shot but it Bernie drops up
people are assuming will go get in line
and support the Democrats no I think
that most of the Bernie bros right the
brown shirt brigade they're either not
going to vote or I think that a
surprising amount of them will actually
vote Donald Trump if they do as opposed
to Joe Biden not saying a majority not
saying a plurality this is one thing
that I'm pretty fortunate to have with
you know over a billion views now on
YouTube I guess we're gonna do a billion
view livestream party when we cross it
as well as The Young Turks
subscribership
behind the behind the scenes we are over
a billion but some of the videos got
removed from YouTube anyway I digress
will do a billion in that videos too but
this is provided me with some analytics
to see that we had a lot of people who
are coming in
angry who were bernie bros back in 2016
when we would do that you know medicare
for all socialized health care in Canada
we always took aim at Bernie because
Hillary Clinton Hillary Clinton was the
coronation Bernie Sanders was the
movement candidate I think you're seeing
that here right now it's a repeat with
Joe Biden and Bernie Sanders we could
see a lot of former Bernie bros turn
into Trump supporters for a couple of
reasons mainly anti-establishment they
felt that it was ready to games Bernie
which by the way I don't know is
altogether an illegitimate argument it
is kind of ironic to me that you have a
party that has super-delegates but
they're against the electoral college it
just seems like they want to choose who
the nominee is who the president is
right they want to be a coronation in a
general election they want the president
to be chosen by Los Angeles Chicago New
York I don't know why went right to
depending on where the map is
my right your left and then they have
super-delegates where they want to
effectively I don't know if it's rigged
that's the system they have but it
allows them more control over who the
nominee is certainly to usurp the will
of the American people so a lot of
Bernie voters I think we'll go to Trump
for the same reason if they want the
Trump over Hillary Clinton
anti-establishment and then again the
idea of tray the idea of being anti-war
that's a wash between Bernie and Donald
Trump but it's actually a leg up for
Donald Trump in contrast with Joe Biden
who was seen as more of a war hawk
something else that I think is important
to note here um well first of that let's
call out the Hillary Clinton effect okay
the Hillary Clinton effect Hillary
Clinton is seen as elitist establishment
and the Rust Belt they didn't like her
because she was basically you know
funded by Wall Street donors and foreign
money so they thought all right Donald
Trump is anti-establishment maybe he
represents us more if it's Joe Biden
you're going to get that affect times
tank can you think of anyone more
establishment than Joe Biden keep in
mind you this is something that people
are missing to give you an idea how
establishment Joe Biden is um
that's the only reason Barack Obama
victim the only reason that he picked
the guy who said you can't walk into a
7-eleven without a slight Indian accent
the guy who said you know Barack Obama
is pretty clean-cut for I think he said
for a colored gentleman or a negro of
something that's offensive that's not
really offensive anyways get a lot of
gas kind of racist I don't think he's
racist the gas were perceived as racist
the only reason Barack Obama picked Joe
Biden
because here was this unknown senator
with effectively no track record and a
Muslim sounding name running for the
highest office in the land and at that
point he was seen as kind of a radical
leftist you know someone who was who was
certainly to the left of Clinton's as we
had known in the past socialist was a
word thrown around and to appease the
moderate Democratic establishment to
show that he could play ball with the
people who have suckled at the
government teat for their entire life he
hand-picked show by the same look my
running mate is a guy who not only has
racist - who not only is whiter than
Larry Bird but he is not worked in the
private sector or ever held a private
job for the last 30 or 40 something odd
years joe biden was bit by Barack Obama
because he couldn't possibly be more
establishment and that foot Barack Obama
needed so now we have Hillary Clinton
times 10 Joe Biden who is in an all-out
turf war with Bernie Sanders who has
shown an outwardly spoken that if he
wins a plurality of the boat he will
burn all of this [ __ ] down and not care
I can't imagine a scenario that is
better for President Donald Trump going
into the general but I reserve the right
to be wrong still hoping for Elizabeth
Warren to be on the show let me know
your thoughts on the Super Tuesday I
guess and please do think of subscribing
the mug club that's what funds us we're
not funded by Al Jazeera or buddy Roman
funded by mugs